have you guys seen this new article from
Common Sense Barry Weiss's sub stack no
crime is a construct my morning with the
Park Slope Panthers wow if you ever
wonder what it would be like for urban
liberals to try and deal with a crime
problem come over to commonsense.news
where Susie Weiss wrote up this article
so I'll give you the gist of because I
want to read everything it's hilarious
and it's terrifying at the same time so
there's this guy he's he calls himself
he says he's left of left of Lenin I
guess yeah he's walking his dog and a
homeless guy whacks his dog with a stick
killing it yeah injured the dog they
brought hospital emergency surgeries
couldn't save it so he decides to start
a group a neighborhood watch called the
Park Slope Panthers why because there's
two Panther statues at the front of the
park that's it
so they have this meeting and then these
uh leftists show up and start saying we
won't abide by your rules you want to
call the cops you're bad
there's infighting it's chaotic they all
start to just generally agree with the
absurdities of the left about no police
and creating a utopian society where
everyone just gets along and they
acknowledge that the homeless guy waving
the stick around beating people and
chasing women is just you know he's
being oppressed by these systems and
rejected and then it ends with them
deciding to you know okay we'll come
back and have another meeting and then
they spray paint they vandalize his home
by writing don't be a cop to the guy
this is what happens when your town is
overrun by crime murders homeless people
and your dog is murdered and you're like
okay the cops aren't helping us can we
start a neighborhood watch Young
leftists show up yell at you everyone
fights and then they vandalize your
house they were like we don't like that
you're stealing Black Culture by calling
it the Panthers and some old woman's
like there's Panther statues right there
that's why we're saying that and then
some lady goes let's call it the Tigers
and it's just like a bunch of extremely
naive people who have no idea how to
deal with why their city is falling
sounds like an SNL skit with us and I
was funny
people were actually asking if this was
satirical or not it sounds fake it
sounds fake hilarious you're not in New
York are you no no I'm here well I'm not
here I'm in DC oh okay but DC is still
pretty bad too it's bad I was you know
telling Lydia this this earlier too you
know I was I've been going to DC a
little more for meetings and everything
now that my babies are a little bit
older and um I can't believe the
homeless encampments and and this is you
know right outside the front door
basically of the CNN building I mean
there's just tents tents everywhere
there's tents all over they're covering
every single Park it's I mean I've never
seen anything like it it's completely
crazy and and it's really sad too
because these people you know it gets
dark and it's it's
like it's like drug City and no one's
doing anything about it and it's violent
and scary and I don't want to walk
around alone in in DC and for a while
there I felt okay doing it do you guys
see Casey neistat is back in New York
City and so he started making Vlogs
again because it's been a while he moved
it's funny he moved out right before the
pandemic and the lockdown and stuff and
everything got really bad then he comes
back right when it's all wrapping up and
uh his videos are great he's just a he's
a happy-go-lucky guy he makes fun videos
I love to watch him but I just wonder if
he's going to talk about that stuff
because this was really interesting in
his latest Vlog he mentions that New
York was being beaten down there was
riding there was looting there were
lockdowns it was brutal and then I was
like whoa this is starting to get good
like case is outright just like New York
was basically Under Siege she was like I
couldn't believe I wasn't here for that
and now he's like I'm back in New York
I'm genuinely wondering if he's gonna be
like crime is through the roof and
people are being murdered and some dude
got pushed under the subway tracks the
other day or if it's just gonna be like
New York is fun and beautiful and it's
the greatest thing ever it's hard to
hide yeah it's hard to hide your
personal experiences especially if
you're doing a personal Vlog so it's
gonna it's going to be interesting to
see a lot of this stuff I I wasn't the
biggest fan of him especially with him
promoting uh rushed experimental
therapies without doctor consultations I
wasn't the biggest fan of him working
with CNN and promoting Hillary Clinton
and you know just naively talking about
politics when he didn't know a lot about
politics so it's going to be interesting
to see his return to New York City I've
been there a couple weeks ago and it's a
crap hole I hate it there's a bunch of
like nasty garbage everywhere there's
there's some it smells everywhere it's
it's bunch of rats everywhere it's not a
fun city it used to be a city where you
felt the energy of the city the city
sometimes you know propped You Up made
you feel like you're on top of the world
sometimes it brought you down to reality
but but it was a roller coaster ride now
it's just continually down and low
vibrational bull crap uh nasty CD
disgusting energy that I just don't want
to be a part of it and I'm absolutely
unhappy it smells like sour milk yeah
absolutely yeah people don't understand
that people it does it literally does
because it's damp and horrible and it's
shaded by all the skyscrapers and it's
just crazy you can actually see in some
areas you'll be walking by like Times
Square and there's a a streak of sour
milk in the gutter when you see that
like cloudy white gray liquid flowing
down the the gutters on the side of the
road and then a little little rat
especially down on in no like Soho like
right right on a Houston Street when you
that's where the fish markets are and
they come out at the end of the day
after just gutting fish all day and they
spray it on the sidewalk with their
hoses into the water into the street
they're not supposed to but everyone
does it everyone doesn't man it's like
the stuff not like dystopian Futures are
made of when you watch what's going on
there where were you when you were there
I'm not telling you because I was on the
upper Upper West Side for an event we
did like four months five months ago and
it was beautiful that long ago it must
have been it was around that time it was
like in the middle like July or June
that's like two months ago yeah uh and
it was phenomenal it was so nice but it
was the Upper West Side yeah or east
side it was like the nicest part of the
city they closed down that fancy boat in
Central Park yeah I saw that yeah I just
you know when I saw that Casey was
saying he was going back to New York I
was kind of just like this kind of feels
like BS to me dude because what is it
like a hundred something thousand
businesses were destroyed in the
lockdowns there's you know going to New
York I mean yeah there's people there
obviously there's millions of people
live there but it's not the same and I
wonder if his real goal is just because
he mentioned in his video that uh it was
being beaten down he wasn't here for it
maybe he just wants to create a positive
image of the city once again or
something I don't know I think I
Right Here and Now
the way people
cities whether they think they're great
like these leftists are on big cities I
think that if someone thinks they're
awesome you can tell that they're
brainwashed because they're not awesome
and I feel like everyone can see that
who's looking at it objectively if you
don't agree that they're kind of
starting to fall apart or actively
falling apart at the end stage of like
near-death experience nonsense then
you're blind well that's that's a thing
too when I so you know Casey comes back
to New York and he's like making videos
again everyone's like he's gonna make
Vlogs and he's talking about how great
it is in New York and he's showing
people like pogoing and other things
like that and I'm just like no you know
this video he's putting out really does
make it seem like New York's awesome and
then I remembered being there a few
months ago and I remember it exactly why
I moved away from it first it was
constant violence uh gunshots ringing
out in the middle of the night in
certain areas where I live because I was
in uh I was in Brooklyn then we had uh
two cops get murdered literally on the
street that I lived on I I guess I'm
just unlucky in that regard but then
there was another story about cops who
walked into um the stairwell of of some
a project housing building and then got
scared in the middle that it was dark
out and fired a bullet which ricocheting
shot a random guy in the chest thing
things like this happen in New York City
because it's it's it's crowded there's
crime people are getting mugged there
was that was it she was 19 year old girl
up at Columbia who got brutally stabbed
to death and so I'm there someone
planted bombs on 25th Street the bomb
went off someone planted bombs on the
Jersey side and I'm just like
you know what you know you know what I
found
I was talking to this couple that were
from South Africa and they told me that
it's not that bad they were like
everybody talks about how bad the crime
is we've only been carjacked I think
five times in South Africa yeah and
that's what they told me only about five
times and I might draw to the floor I'm
like five I was there I remember that we
were in uh what country Korea Korea yeah
you're in Korea and I was like that's
kind of bad and they were like to them
it's like my friends have been carjacked
ten times me only five therefore crimes
not that bad as people as bad as people
say and it's like I'm from Chicago I've
never been carjacked so people in New
York City right now it is bad there was
a I mean let me let me show you this
right here from from Barry Weiss's from
Susie Weiss's article this is I wonder
if she's related to Barry she says in
the last couple of months in Park Slope
the Baby Bjorn wearing capital of
Bourgeois Bohemian New York a thief
absconded with 200 000 worth of Jewelry
in a smash and grab three boys sold a
bunch of iPhones off Subway Riders a
ticked off customer attacked the owner
of a bike store six thousand dollars was
stolen from an auto shop and a beloved
bet was cat-napped from a bodega on 7th
Avenue this is just park slope and then
the story of the main guy and then in
the on August 3rd moose a dog was uh uh
and his owner Jessica were out on a walk
when a homeless man gave Chase and hit
them both with a large stick and threw a
container of urine on moose while
muttering about immigrants amazing the
dog died a few days later this is just
Park Slope it's one small area of
Brooklyn to come out and try and act
like cities are doing well I get you
want to have a positive image that that
I can respect but I just come on man
yeah it really is it's bad it's a wonder
of the world New York City will be
looked at as like one of the great
wonders of Earth in the future aspects
of it you know the Statue of Liberty the
World Trade Center the Empire State
Building and Central Park
um and it's it's incredible to take it
in and see it and to be there and to
come up from the subway for the first
time and look up to 80 story skyscrapers
all around you like there's a vacuum
that sucks your soul but living there I
mean you got to use reason and logic and
decide if you want to be packed like a
sardine into a city with a bunch of
other people where it smells yeah like
sour milk and other chemicals well it's
just it's concerning how just like
empathy just dies like you just stop
caring for your fellow man or something
and it's just like
you're just out for yourself in New York
and you don't it doesn't matter who you
step on what you're running over what
it's just it's
yeah that happened to me ugly that
happened to me I was coming back from
work after an hour and a half commute
for like the 30th day in a row and there
was a woman in front of me with a bunch
of bags on the stairs going down taking
up like three there's width for three
people to go up and down the steps but
she was taking up the entire width so I
put my hand on her shoulder and pushed
her aside not hard but I realized after
I did that I just pushed a woman what's
happening because if after her there's
going to be another person in front of
you and then another one checking their
phone and they don't see you and it's
like I it's it's utilitarian you can't
you can't function when people are in
your way well it's like those videos uh
in Japan when you have like subway
pushers like it's like it's like you
stop being human it's like you just stop
being yeah and now you guys understand
Bill Gates
and I just interject real fast Vanessa
and I were talking about this and I
suspect that what's happening in cities
is because everyone's crammed in on top
of each other I think this shortens
their lifespan of like their livability
yeah because everyone squeezed together
people just become objects that you have
to run over into they get in your way
they walk slow they drive slow they
fumble around at the cash register it's
irritating when you have too many
interactions with other people I don't
think people are designed to live in
cities you're not supposed to live in a
shoe box that smells like cereal milk
yeah you're not thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through to
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there